هنا متواجدين في مدرسه العروبه غرب مخيم
النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه حيث اغارت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه بعده صواريخ ودمرت
هذه المدرسه بشكل كامل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه اغارت وبدون سابق انذار على
هذه المدرسه التي كانت في الايام السابقه
تحوي بداخلها على اعداد كبيره من النازحين
الفلسطينيين هذا المربع السكني قد تضرر
بشكل كامل وبشكل كبير جراء هذه الغاره
الاسرائيليه العنيفه هناك عدد من مدارس
الاونر وايضا التي هي بجوار هذه المدرسه
مباشره تضررت بشكل مباشر جراء هذه الغاره
وتم ايضا نقل عدد من الاصابات من داخل هذه
المدارس الي كان بداخلها اعداد من
المواطنين الفلسطينيين الساعه التاسعه ال
ربع تقريبا استهدفوه بخمس صواريخ انفجر
ثلاثه ثلاث صواريخ صواريخ قويه
جدا استطاعت هذه الصواريخ ان تدمر المدرسه
[موسيقى]
انا بالمدرسه المقابله
ها قصفوا المدرسه العروبه ونحنا كثير
خايفين بالليل قصفها وكانوا جنبينا صف وقع
عليهم القزاز وتصوب
كثير
تال
اما هنا في مدينه دير البلح وبالتحديد
منزل عائله ابو عويلي والتي ارتكبت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه بحقهم مجزره
ارتقى من خلالها 11د شهيدا خلال الساعات
الماضيه تم تدمير هذه الشقق السكنيه في
هذه البنايه هنا بدون سابق انظار يتحدثون
اصحاب المنزل والذين نجوا باعجوبه من هذه
الغاره الاسرائيليه عن قصف عنيف استهدف
هذه الشقق السكنيه في كانوا اطفال وفي ناز
كانوا في الدار الشقه مليانه نازحين وكل
نزل علينا الصواريخ من غير سابق اندار ولا
شيء والدار مليانه اطفال وهذا هو الحال
يعني حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل 11 نفر منهم
اربع نسوان والباقي كلهم
اطفال الموجودين كانوا في البيت ولا واحد
طلع منهم عايش والله احنا قاعدين في
هالبيت يعني بدنا ادل العشاء وبدنا نصلي
العشاء ما شفنا الا غير و الحجار بهيل
علينا وصرنا نصرخ ونصوت وصار عننا يعني
حدا شهيد والسع في صباه